hi guys ow you're biting my hair you're
biting my hair just
got a big box
in the mail i know what it is it's
rock band because i just pre-ordered it
i somehow forgot that this was coming
out and months ago i'm like i gotta make
sure i pre-order and i pre-ordered two
days ago and it got here a day after the
release date so maddie hey i got the
xbox one band in a box careful baby
because we've got a knife here and this
is very sharp
you can't understand a word i'm saying
what have you got on your face okay just
you can bite my arm just stay away from
the knife that's
that's not for you
what's in here aerosmith avenged seven
fold black keys
oh my gosh van halen you too system
system went down you guys will
understand
i
used to be obsessed with system of a
down
come on peggy move it saw van halen
three days ago what a great mix of
people imagine dragons
stop this
you're going to draw blood and i'm going
to be upset
come on get out of here
i don't want to sit on this knife
everything that i'm doing is not good
beep beep who's got the keys to the jeep
clearly not you all right well now that
he's found another box that you want
this is making me extremely nervous come
over here good boy
stay over there stay over here
if you guys are wondering about his
little sweater it's an anxiety sweater
because he's been itching and biting
himself okay you wanna sit on my lap oh
my god i remember playing
like the original rock band
a long time ago
very
very long time ago are you sealed again
this is a rough box opening
this is what we call fun
here's our drums
i'm pumped for this man i'm super stoked
you look good i just want to look good
for you good
i just want to look okay oh instructions
stop if you experience any setup or
mechanical problems contact madcatz for
setup or other technical sports all
right
now call me maybe
take it
all right nothing else of importance
in there important
important important
oh my god i'm not gonna be good at this
it's been way too long you've got a
piece of plastic in your mouth what the
hell do you think you're doing you don't
do that but he's a dog he doesn't know
any better
you smell like you need a bath
that's gonna have to be adjusted so
we're gonna have to deal with that later
what's in here
oh i think that i found myself a
cheerleader
maddie's always right here you can't
play that
maddy i'm gonna be drummond
you're gonna be
so into these sticks
i'll read the directions they say no
this looks like you go
here
maddie you can't fit under the couch
anymore
oh that's not good
you
look like you might go here
do you go here hi so i was just editing
my rock band video and i realized that
half of the video cut off and there was
no audio so it's set up we're here we're
ready
uh my son was just picked up and i'm
probably gonna get a copyright strike so
i'll see you guys soon i'm really
excited to play rock band let me know
what your favorite rock band song is if
you got the new rock band 4 if you
didn't well
i mean rock band is fun maddie look you
got a new you got a new shirt today
you're having fun playing rock band do
you want to come over here you guys like
my call of duty sweatpants i'm real
fashion forward today go right here
good boy look at his tail so long he's
got hiccups he just ate dinner oh he
wants to go outside huh
i'm just gonna act like i didn't see
that because
we were just outside a little bit ago
and i don't want to go back up and it's
way too hot stay tuned for some possible
gameplay videos i'm not sure i haven't
figured out if i'm going to post
something or not we'll see i've just
been playing video games and not posting
so i'm sorry but i've been having fun so
i'll see you later bye
are you just are you showing off the
camera because usually you run away like
a crazy little boy
we gotta go